hello everyone and welcome back to the
bullet Chess Championship It's the final
it's not the Grand Final only the final
you know that after this is over we
still have more uh bullets to enjoy yeah
it's Hikaru Nakamura versus salireza
firucha as you can see I've reverted
back to the old uh interface I have
fixed the aspect ratio though so until I
come up with something new uh I will be
using this one like I mentioned in the
previous few videos so let's check it
out it's one of the games I'm not gonna
spoil the results for uh some of you
that haven't seen it yet uh as some of
you were very unhappy with that in the
previous video so let's just check it
out and then we are going to discuss
what happened so Hikaru with the white
pieces opens with Ponte E4 and like I
said this is one plus zero bullet chess
uh incredibly uh quick moves are
required here in order to just be able
to compete and of course incredibly
precise moves some of the games have
over 90 percent uh accuracy so a lot I
mean like I said just absolutely
incredible Pawn to E5 Knight the C3
Hikaru goes for the Vienna game Knight
the C6 and the bishop to C4 now we have
Bishop to C5 and now for those of you
who are who are wondering you cannot
play the Evans Gambit here because
there's a knight on C3 so you know you
would have some problems trying to
execute that so D3 uh and now D6 is the
most common move here in pretty much
everyone plays it but Knight to the A5
while it is uh trying to mix it up a
little bit Hikaru just plays Knight to
F3 well it is that grabs the light
Square Bishop which is usually excellent
the captures and now Pawn to D6 and here
there are some games for Queen to D3
also H3 is a normal but here Hikaru just
castles and it is now as of move 7 that
we have a completely new game
so Hikaru can't really claim any sort of
um an edge here as he did lose the the
bishop pair also his pawns are doubled
but he does have very nice control over
the D5 Square so okay Knight D7 uh we
have Knights the a for now going after
alirez's bishop and pawn to B6 the
latest wants to do the same and should
uh Hikaru capture then just be captures
uh and okay you have a nice semi-open B
file for your Rook you have very nice
control over the D4 Square so uh not
something to uh to actually give black
for no reason so Pawn to A3 Hikaru just
prepares Pawn to B4 and pawn to A5 here
all it is of course stops it we have
Pawn to C3 and the bishop to D7 putting
pressure on the Knight here we have Pawn
to B4 and now alireza trades Bishop
captures an A4 attacks he calls Queen on
D1 Queen captures an A4 comes with check
and of course you are wondering but what
about the bishop and C5 hanging the the
isn't this just completely winning for
for white well not quite because there's
B5 now the queen is hanging and of
course if you move the queen then we're
gonna play captures on B4 and so on and
if you capture further which isn't all
that great for example C6 B for now B
cap a cap or some B4 opens up a
discovery on the queen and the once the
queen moves now you will also play B
captures on C3 and it's a perfectly fine
position let's say characters and
castles so instead Hikaru plays the
absolute best move he goes back with
Queen to B3 with eight characters on B4
C capture some B4 attacks the bishop and
now a nice position to buy algireza B
captures and C4 attacks he cars Queen
captures and now Bishop to B6 and just
Rook to D1 so now you have to be careful
Knight captures on E5 is the threat as
the d-pawn is pinned so alireza defends
it and now Pawn to A4
uh what you can see out of all of this
is that even though the material is
completely even he covered us have the
past a pawn and whatever happens in this
game he should always be a little bit
better so castles and now Pawn to A5
chases away the bishop Bishop A7 and now
Bishop to D2 so all it is Bishop is an
absolute monster here uh he calls Bishop
not all that impressive you can't even
put it on some long diagonal here so
chances are Hikaru will trade it off for
this strong Bishop on A7 we have King to
h8 getting off of this diagonal and now
Rook 8 to C1 we have rooked the C8
adding a Defender to the C7 pawn and the
bishop to E3 uh very principle move just
trading off your piece that isn't doing
all that much for your opponent's piece
which is just excellent so Bishop
captures with f captures yes this
doubles he corresponds but also he gains
control over the F4 Square so he doesn't
have to worry about Knight to F4 or
anything like that also you don't have
to worry about the queen entering the
game deny discovering that but you have
to to worry about Knights the H4 and
this is exactly what alireza plays but
Hikaru just defends the Knight with
Queen to E2 here it's a very very rich
position and you could win the game on
the spot by playing Knight captures on
H4 but remember it's a OnePlus 0 bullet
and after Queen captures there's Rook
captures on D6 just snatching another
pawn another problem is of course
um uh you're you're done too much
material and of course if you capture
then you just either get the checkmated
if the queen is captured or if you don't
then King to G8 you defend but then just
Queen to C4 and you now have two
connected pass pawns uh well of course
completely winning uh but okay the
bullet Hikaru played Queen back to E2
with Ponte F5 and now e captures on F5
we have Knight captures on F5 and now
Pawn to E4 chasing away the knight from
such an active square and the problem is
of course wherever the Knight goes you
will most likely play Knight captures on
E5 as the Deep one is still pinned we
already discussed that you could play
Knight H6 here okay Knight captures um
on E5 is not gonna be that impressive
now uh but uh you know you can just play
Pokemon to B5 Pawn to A6 and continue
pushing so uh it's not it's not the best
but also the Knight on H6 isn't all that
great and of course here if you play
Knight captures an E5 then comes C5 and
it's not it's just not as bad also the
G4 square is nicely covered so what um
what do you play here if you if you try
to play one to B5 then lose the A5 Pawn
so it would be it would be an okay way
to play but it's really weird putting
your knight on H6 so it is to give give
up a pawn he played Knight D7 and Hikaru
captured it Knight captures on E5 with
Queen to E8 and now Knight back to F3 we
have Knight to G6 and now Pawn to G3
taking away the F4 and H4 squares from
uh Alvarez's Knight here Queen to E6 and
now we have Knights the D4 attacking the
queen here Queen to H3 and now Rook to
F1 uh Knight to F5 also just a beautiful
move there taking away the FL from the
black Rook but Rook to F1 also very nice
we have Knight the E5 battle it is a and
now just Pawn to A6 Hikaru continues
pushing his pass pawn and now Pawn to H5
so as you can see there's no more
counting pawns here it's do or die
no more time to spend on which Pawn goes
where and of course uh he always just
wants to play H4 open up the position
and somehow try to attack the
uh the white king also Knight coming to
G4 could be an issue you if the Queen
ever moves from the defense of the H2
Pawn so here Pawn to A7 again you have a
beautiful pass ball on A7 uh Pawn to H4
by alireza and now Rook captures an f8
with check Rook campus and now Queen to
H5 with check we have King to G8 and now
even Queen captures on H4 so while you
are winning material you are also sort
of allowing the Larissa back into the
game Queen to D7 and now Queen to H5
again Rook to F1 was absolutely crushing
but he power played Queen to H5 and now
alireza can bounce back in the game with
Pawn to C5 uh attacks the Knight and the
pawn here so you have to trade or Knight
to F5 and now Queen captures an A7 and
now alireza is completely back in the
game B captures and C5 we have D
captures on C5 and now King to G2 we
have Queen to A2 with check and King the
H3 and now we have Queen the E6 and uh
captures in C5 now uh putting pressure
on them on the night here so the queen
can't really move just anywhere and what
you should play is Rook to f60 it's such
a such strong move also prevents the
knight from moving because of Rook to H6
but alireza played Pawn to G6 with a
double attack on the Knight end on the
queen but this of course completely
blunders the game for him and I'm sure
you guys can see why feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Hikaru
here while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible tactic and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook captures on E5 that's it it's as
simple as that just remove the defender
of the G6 pawn and you're winning of
course now if you try trading Queens
then uh you're gonna end up this being
down a night and the Knight here is
defended so you can't play that so all
it is to play the Queen captures on E5
but now comes Knight to H6 with check
and now also Hikaru will win alireza's
Queen King date Queen captures an E5
with check and he was in this position
unmove uh 44 that alireza fioricia
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here of course so you
are completely winning and for those of
you who for some reason enjoy it when I
finish the games until the very end okay
let's see something like King the H7
Queen to E7 with check you can even pick
up a rook here let's say a queen
captures and f8 King H7 and now you will
box in the black king and Checkmate and
let's say whatever you play let's say
one to G5 You'll Play upon the E5 King
to G6 now you're going to play Queen to
G8 with check King to H6 King to F5 and
that's pretty much it King to H5 and
queen captures and G5 and this will of
course be Checkmate I don't know why
sometimes it went even it doesn't matter
how much white or black is up in
material some of you really enjoy it
when I finish the games so there you
have it and uh yeah some uh very nicely
done by akikaru he also won the match 16
and a half to 12 and a half and I wrote
on Twitter something that some people uh
didn't seem to agree with I said that in
in bullet in bullet time control but not
like one plus one bullet or one plus
something in one plus zero uh that
Hikaru is definitely the best then it
could be alireza and only then Magna
says I it's one plus zero is very very
different from one plus one now magnets
of course will get his chance to climb
back up and face uh Hikaru in the Grand
Final but until then I will I just have
to you know stick with that and all it
is all it is actually replied to my uh
tweet he said that you know it's still
early that we're gonna see what happens
but um yeah I don't know and I also
think uh yeah uh asios mentioned on
Twitter that it's a very much different
uh OnePlus zero where you are playing uh
meaning on what on which platform uh
because on chess.com even when you
pre-move you lose time you lose like a
fraction of a second then unleashes when
you pre-move you don't lose any time so
it's uh if you're a good pre-mover you
get a lot more moves in and leeches uh
also one of the reasons why I prefer
playing on leeches uh but we'll see I
think on leeches in OnePlus zero uh
Magnus uh you know uh trumps everyone on
chess.com not really sure and uh with
one plus one and Magnus I believe
crushes anyone on any platform but we'll
see this is one plus zero and chase.com
so it's a it's a different Beast uh so
yeah and that's the game I hope you you
guys enjoyed it let me know if you if
you have an opinion on that it's uh you
know it's a weird thing to debate but so
it's pretty much everything on the
internet I would like to thank James
Eugene Cashman Brad Roth Michael
Marshall bullet just thriller.com and
John Malpass for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day